[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe
unseres täglichen True Crime Podcasts
Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer wir
nehmen Euch heute mit in die USA der
80er Jahre und erzählen euch von Robert
bardella einem Mann der zwischen 1984
und 1988 mindestens sechs Männer
entführt manchmal über Wochen hinweg
gefoltert und schließlich ermordet hat
er gilt als einer der grausamsten
Serienmörder der amerikanischen
Geschichte und heute ist auf jeden Fall
eine triggerwarnung angebracht es geht
um Vergewaltigung sexualisierte Gewalt
und Folter und diese Geschichte ist
absolut nichts für schwache Nerven
okay ihr seid gewarnt Mirko wer war
Robert bedella der schlechter von Kansas
City naja ein sehr spezieller Charakter
wie man sich vielleicht jetzt schon
vorstellen kann aber natürlich wurde er
nicht als grausamer Mörder geboren im
Gegenteil dem kleinen Robert hätte wohl
niemand so etwas zugetraut aber das ist
ja eigentlich immer so oder man sieht es
niemandem an und schon gar nicht als
Kind ja es gibt ja auch keinen
vorgezeichneten Lebensweg der einen
Menschen unweigerlich zu Mörder macht
Robert bordella kommt 1949 in Ohio zur
Welt die Familie ist katholisch sein
Vater sehr streng er und sein jüngerer
Bruder geben sich alle Mühe seine
Erwartungen zu erfüllen um Bestrafungen
zu entgehen in den Augen anderer macht
sie das zu wohlerzogenen Kindern robert
ist allerdings auch sehr unsportlich hat
eine Sprachstörung und trägt eine dicke
Brille was ihn zu einem leichten Opfer
von Mobbing in der Schule macht
er entwickelt sich zum Außenseiter
spielt kaum draußen und hat wenig
Freunde stattdessen malt er sammelt
Briefmarken und Münzen und pflegt
Brieffreundschaften in Länder wie
Vietnam und Burma dass er so unsportlich
ist
ärgert vor allem seinen Vater der in ihm
einen Versager sieht
Robert bekommt seine ganze Wut zu spüren
und wird unter anderem mit einem
Ledergürtel verprügelt
trotzdem ist er ein ziemlich guter
Schüler und wohl auch künstlerisch
begabt als Teenager entdeckt er seine
Homosexualität das Zelt der viele Jahre
geheim und hat für kurze Zeit sogar eine
Freundin aber weiter im Lebenslauf
1965 stirbt sein Vater überraschend an
einem Herzinfarkt da ist Robert gerade
mal 17 Jahre alt den jungen Mann trifft
der Verlust sehr hart das klingt seltsam
wenn man bedenkt wie der Vater ihn
behandelt bzw er misshandelt hat aber so
ist es die Mutter heiratet nur wenige
Monate später erneut und Robert
empfindet das als Verrat es scheint ihm
als würde die Mutter die Erinnerung an
den Vater beschmutzen wie kann sie sich
einen neuen Mann suchen während er
selbst noch immer trauert er sucht Trost
in der Religion zuerst im Katholizismus
später in diversen anderen
Glaubensrichtungen doch der Trost bleibt
aus
Robert wendet sich vom Glauben ab und
hat bald nur noch Verachtung für ihn
übrig dazu beigetragen hat vermutlich
auch ein traumatisches Erlebnis bei
einem Job wird er von einem älteren
Mitarbeiter sexuell missbraucht kurz
darauf verlässt er die katholische
Kirche für immer
1965 das Todesjahr seines Vaters war
noch in anderer Hinsicht bedeutsam für
seine spätere Entwicklung also seinem
Weg zum Massenmörder er sieht im Kino
den Film der Fänger er handelt von einem
unauffälligen Mann der in seiner
Freizeit Schmetterlinge sammelt um sich
an ihrer Schönheit zu erfreuen er fühlt
sich zu einer attraktiven Kunststudentin
hingezogen es gelingt ihm jedoch
aufgrund seiner sozialen Unfähigkeiten
nicht mit ihr in Kontakt zu kommen und
so beschließt er sie seiner Sammlung
schöner Dinge einzufleiden entführt sie
und hält sie in seinem Keller gefangen
der Film macht einen so starken Eindruck
auf den Jungen bei della dass er
beschließt ihn im echten Leben
nachzustellen bis er diesen Plan in die
Tat umsetzt Vergehen allerdings noch
fast zwei Jahrzehnte
1967 beendet er die Highschool und geht
nach Kansas City um Kunst zu studieren
er gilt als begabt und sehr ehrgeizig
in dieser Zeit beginnt der zu trinken
und Drogen an seine Kommilitonen zu
verkaufen er wird geschnappt als er
versucht metametamine an einen
Undercover-Polizisten zu verkaufen und
wird zu einer fünfjährigen
Bewährungsstrafe verurteilt der
zurückgezogene schüchterne Junge
entwickelt sich in dieser Zeit zu einem
selbstbewussten jungen Mann ein bisschen
zu selbstbewusst könnte man sagen er
hält sich für überlegen und behandelt
vor allem Frauen sehr herablassend sein
Traum von einer Karriere als
Kunstprofessor Platz 1969 im Rahmen
eines Kunstprojekts hatte er eine Ente
geköpft für ein anderes Projekt
experimentierte er mit Hunden und
Beruhigungsmitteln und tötete
schließlich einen Hund vor Publikum
alles für die Kunst aber Freiheit der
Kunst hin oder her das geht der
Universität eindeutig zu weit und Robert
bedala fliegt von der Hochschule Werbung
[Musik]
was hat Sauce Bernaise mit Erregung
öffentlichen Ärgernisses zu tun und
kommt man wegen Oralverkehr während der
Periode in den Knast um diese und mehr
pikante Fragen geht es in der neuen sixx
Eigenproduktion Sex crime Stories Paula
im True Crime Fieber in insgesamt sechs
Episoden trifft six sex-expertin Paula
Lambert dem bekannten Strafverteidiger
Bestsellerautor und Podcaster dr
Alexander Stevens er berichtet von den
skurrilsten spannendsten und
schockierendsten sexuellen motivierten
Fällen seiner Laufbahn aber keine Sorge
das klingt jetzt etwas brutal aber es
geht in dem Format nicht um sexuelle
Gewalt viel mehr geht es um echte Fälle
die vor Gericht verhandelt wurden mit
überraschenden und skurrilen Wendungen
bei diesem Format verschlägt es sogar
der sonst sofortgewandten Paula Lambert
die Sprache auch ich muss sagen die
Fälle sind teilweise kaum zu glauben und
es gibt immer wieder viel zu schmunzeln
also verpasst nicht sexcrime Stories
Paula im truecrime Fieber ab 6 Februar
immer montags um 20 Uhr auf sixx
Werbung Ende
in Hyde Park einem Stadtteil von Kansas
City findet bei della ein neues Zuhause
in der charlitz Street einem hübschen
weiß gestrichenen Reihenhaus das ist so
ein typisches amerikanisches
vorstadthäuschen genau sehr gemütlich
und friedlich in einer ruhigen
Nachbarschaft Walt Disney hat hier
gewohnt bevor er nach Kalifornien ging
aber wie wir aus unzähligen Filmen und
Serien Wissen verbirgt sich hinter
dieser Fassade oft genug das Tor zur
Hölle oh ja und dieser Fall zeigt dass
die Filme da nicht ganz unrecht haben
erst einmal scheint es aber als sei da
ein echt netter Kerl in die Gegend
gezogen okay er verbringt viel Zeit mit
männlichen Prostituierten mit
Drogenabhängigen und Ausreißern und das
wird sicher nicht allen Recht gewesen
sein aber bei della besteht bis zu
seinem Tod darauf dass es ihm zu jener
Zeit nicht um Sex geht er will ihnen
helfen fühlt sich als eine Art
Pflegevater und baut Freundschaften zu
den jungen Männern auf
so sagt er zumindest tatsächlich hat er
zu vielen von ihnen sexuelle Beziehungen
und versucht sie unter seine Kontrolle
zu bringen zum Beispiel indem er ihnen
Geld borgt oder sie mietfrei bei sich
wohnen lässt bei den Nachbarn jedenfalls
geht er als hilfsbereiter Mensch und so
sieht man über seine Extravaganzen
hinweg genauso wie über sein chaotisches
Grundstück und seine Arroganz bei della
engagiert sich in einem Zusammenschluss
von Nachbarn die Verbrechen in der
Gegend verhindern wollen in den frühen
80ern wird er dort sogar Vorsitzender
und regt nachbarschaftpatronen an erst
Mitte der 80er liegt er den Posten
nieder da ist er schon längst ein Mörder
das finde ich so krass naja aber in den
70ern ist bordella jobtechnisch
zumindest ein Flickenteppich er arbeitet
als Koch ist so eine Art Springer wird
gerufen wenn Not am Mann ist und lernt
auf diese Weise viele Restaurants kennen
nebenher züchtet er Hunde genauer gesagt
ciao ciao das sind diese kleinen
knuffigen pelzinger von zu Hause aus
verkauft er Antiquitäten und Raritäten
die er zum Teil von seinem Brieffreunden
in Afrika Asien und Südamerika bezieht
es läuft gut für ihn er wird zum
Chefkoch befördert und mietet einen
Stand auf dem Westport Flohmarkt den er
Box besah bisa nennt und wo er von nun
an seine Antiquitäten verkauft und dort
lernt der Paul Haul kennen
der betreibt den stand neben dem
basarbisar die beiden freunden sich an
mit Pauls und Jerry Haul gibt es anfangs
Probleme der Teenager verspottet Robert
wegen dessen nun offengelebter
Homosexualität doch bald werden auch die
beiden zu Freunden
währenddessen wächst etwas in Robert
etwas Schreckliches düsteres
es ist der Drang zu quälen und der Drang
das auszuprobieren was er im Film
gesehen und als Kunststudent an Tieren
existiert hat nur eben diesmal ein
Menschen
am 4 juli 1984 bricht das Böse hervor
[Musik]
Jerry Howell Schulter Robert bei della
Geld seit einiger Zeit geht der
19-Jährige dem Freund seines Vaters aus
dem Weg er hat ein schlechtes Gewissen
und fürchtet die Wut des anderen doch
wie es scheint hat er sich umsonst
Sorgen gemacht wird der la taucht gegen
Abend im Haus der Haus auf an diesem Tag
findet in einem Nachbarort ein
Tanzwettbewerb statt und bordella bietet
dem Teenager an ihn dorthin zu fahren
Jerry akzeptiert erleichtert dass keine
Rede von dem geborgten Geld ist
im Auto bietet ihm bordella dann einen
Drink an als Jerry bemerkt dass sie
nicht zu dem Tanzwettbewerb unterwegs
sind ist es zu spät der Drink war mit
Beruhigungsmitteln versetzt die bordella
offiziell für seine Hundezucht erworben
und seit langem für den richtigen Moment
gehortet hat er fährt mit dem Auto
ziellos durch die Gegend bis er sicher
ist dass der Teenager das Bewusstsein
verloren hat dann kehrt er in die Schale
Street zurück schleppt den Jungen in
sein Haus und fesselt ihn ans Bett es
ist die Erfüllung seiner perversen
Träume ein junger Mann hilflos ihm
völlig ausgeliefert
kein Mensch mehr für ihn ein Objekt das
er bewundern quälen und vergewaltigen
kann er will nicht töten zumindest ist
das nicht seine Hauptmotivation er will
besitzen und er will wissen wie viel
Schmerz und Zerstörung er einem anderen
zufügen kann
immer wieder vergewaltigt er sein Opfer
auch mit Gegenständen die am Haus findet
er notiert akribisch alles was er ihm
antut auf loses Papier und dokumentiert
seine Verbrechen mit Polaroid Fotos
wenn der Junge zu aktiv wird versetzte
ihm eine neue Dosis Beruhigungsmittel
als der nächste Tag anbricht verlässt er
wie immer sein Haus und geht zur Arbeit
um keinen Verdacht zu wecken als er
zurückkommt steckt er voller neuer Ideen
für noch schlimmere Torturen
das Leiden von Jerry Hall dauert 28
Stunden kurz vor Mitternacht am 5 juli
1984 stirbt er in der Gewalt seines
Peinigers
Adela gibt später an dass er wohl
entweder an seinem Erbrochenen erstickt
sei Jerry war über lange Zeit geknebelt
oder das wegen der vielen
Beruhigungsmittel sein Atem einfach
ausgesetzt habe
versucht den jungen wiederzubeleben
schließlich hat er noch so viel vor mit
ihm doch nach kurzer Zeit gibt er auf
und schleift die Leiche in seinen Keller
dort beginnt das was ihm den Beinamen
der schlechter einbringen wird
er hängt Jerry Howards Körper kopfüber
an der Decke auf unter der Leiche
platziert er einen großen Topf dann
macht er mehrere Einschnitte an den
Armen und der Halsschlagader des Jungen
und lässt ihn über Nacht ausbluten
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen
despektierlich aber was war das bitte
für ein Topf aber gut er war Koch und er
wusste wahrscheinlich schon vorher wozu
er ihn eines Tages brauchen würde am
nächsten Tag zerstückelt bordella den
Körper seines Opfers mit ausbeinmessern
und einer Kettensäge die Leichenteile
packte ein Hundefutter Tüten die er in
größere Müllsäcke schmeißt und vor dem
Haus für die Müllabfuhr abstellt
Jerry Holz Leiche verschwindet für immer
auf einer Deponie in Missouri
auf der Suche nach dem vermissten Jerry
Haul kommt die Polizei natürlich sehr
schnell auf den Mann der ihn zu seinem
Tanzwettbewerb fahren wollte
Bar della behauptet er habe ihn in der
Nähe des Veranstaltungsortes abgesetzt
und seither nicht mehr gesehen er kommt
damit durch und hat jetzt das gefunden
was er für seine Bestimmung hält
bis 1988 gehen fünf weitere junge Männer
durch die Hölle sterben in der
Gefangenschaft des schlechters und
werden von ihm wie viel zerlegt sein
zweites Opfer ist der 20-Jährige Robert
Sheldon ein ehemaliger Untermieter bei
der lass der ihn am 10 April 1985 bittet
noch einmal eine Zeit lang bei ihm
wohnen zu können zwei Tage später
beschließt Robert bedella ihn unter
Drogen zu setzen und gefangen zu nehmen
er foltert ihn mit Abflussreiniger
Dichtungsmittel Nadeln und klavierseiten
am 15 April stehen Arbeiten am Dach von
bödelas Haus an bevor die Arbeiter
kommen erstickt er sein Opfer und
zerlegt die Leiche im Badezimmer im Juni
fällt die Marke Wallace zum Opfer
bordella quält ihn mit Elektroschocks
und Injektionsnadeln
er stirbt nach weniger als 24 Stunden an
einer Kombination aus Drogen dem Knebel
und Sauerstoffmangel am 23 juni um 19
Uhr so notiert ist der Killer akribisch
in seinen Aufzeichnungen
danach perfektioniert wird er da sein
System seine Folter wird immer grausamer
und perfida gleichzeitig gelingt es ihm
die Opfer länger am Leben zu halten
trotz 23 Jahre erleide 2 Wochen
unvorstellbare Quallen in der
Gefangenschaft bevor er wegen innerer
Verletzungen an einer Blutvergiftung
stirbt das Martyrium des 20-Jährigen
Larry Wayne Pearson dauert noch länger
beschreibt ihn später als das
kooperativste seiner Opfer doch nach
sechs Wochen Gefangenschaft und Folter
beißt er seinem Peiniger tief in den
Penis
schlägt ihn daraufhin mit einem Knüppel
bewusstlos
dann fährt er einen Krankenhaus um seine
Verletzung behandeln zu lassen
Christopher Bryson 22 Jahre alt wird
bodellas letztes Opfer und kleiner
Lichtblick er überlebt am 29 März 1988
lockt der Mörder ihn in sein Haus und
schlägt ihn mit einer Eisenstange
bewusstlos dann fesselt er ihn ans Bett
Brighton muss dieselben Qualen adulten
wie die jungen Männer vor ihm am vierten
Tag kann er sich jedoch befreien wird
Ella hat Streichhölzer liegen gelassen
damit verbrennt Christopher seine
Fesseln dann springt er aus einem
Fenster im zweiten Stock bricht sich
dabei einen Fuß kann aber zu einem Mann
Rennen der in der Straße Zähler abliest
und im zurufen dass er die Polizei
alarmieren soll
Bryson ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt nackt um
seinen Hals liegt eine Hundeleine kurz
darauf wird bei della festgenommen in
seinem Haus und Garten finden sich
unzählige Beweisstücke darunter seine
folterprotokolle und hunderte von
Polaroid die das Grauen in seinem ganzen
Ausmaß und allen Details dokumentieren
wird der la bleibt als Gegenleistung für
ein umfassendes Geständnis die
Todesstrafe erspart in einer seiner
Aussagen spricht der über sein
Verhältnis zu den Opfern
das waren keine Menschen an die ich
dachte nachdem ich sie gefesselt hatte
und sie benutzte
sie wurden für mich zu etwas anderem als
Menschen
der Fantasy-Autor Terry pratchet hat
einmal gesagt das Böse beginnt wenn sie
anfangen Menschen als Dinge zu behandeln
Robert burdella verkörpert das absolut
Böse
1994 stirbt Robert burdella in Haft an
einem Herzinfarkt
das absolut Böse hat ein wirklich
makaberes Nachspiel in dem Versuch das
schreckliche zu verarbeiten dass in
ihrer Stadt geschehen ist flüchten sich
einige in morbiden Humor ein
Radiomoderator dichtet beispielsweise
den 60er Jahre Hit mellow yellow in eine
Parodie auf die Mordserie um angeblich
ruft Fox Radio seine Hörer sogar dazu
auf mit Hundehalsband und Leine zum
Sender zu kommen um einen Preis zu
gewinnen also ganz ehrlich jeder hat
seine eigene Art mit dem grauen
umzugehen aber das ganz ehrlich allein
die Vorstellung dass die Angehörigen der
Opfer dieses Leid im Radio anhören
mussten grässlich ja grässlich das
perfekte Schlusswort für die ganze
Geschichte
wir sind für heute fertig fix und fertig
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und dafür
dass ihr mit uns in diese Hölle
gestiegen seid Hölle ja definitiv das
trifft's Malko danke dass ihr dabei wart
wir haben die Geschichte des schlechters
von Kansas City anhand von Quellen in
the mirror und the pitch erzählt eine
große Hilfe waren auch der sehr
ausführliche englischsprachige
Wikipedia-Artikel zu Robert bardella und
ein Interview dass der Mörder im
Gefängnis gab wir freuen uns wenn ihr
auch nächstes Mal wieder dabei seid euer
Mirko und eure Toni
Redaktion und Produktion Stefan
Netzeband und Antonia Heyer
post-words Studios München